i think it has to do with the u.s
diplomat that admits to telling
commander-in-chief lies about troop
levels in syria
i think that there's something going on
here why were they lying to the
president about the levels of troops in
syria when he wanted to withdraw we are
not in control
the the american people lost control a
long time ago this is this was the most
infuriating thing i tell you man when i
when i read this story
i almost punched a hole in my monitor
donald trump
wanted to withdraw our troops from syria
and u.s officials
lied to him and us about how many troops
we have in syria
and then all the democrats and
republicans were like trump trump you
can't withdraw all of our troops from
syria
leave in a certain number so trump
agreed okay we'll leave in 200.
trump famously then holds a press
conference where he's like they want us
to guard the oil so we're going to keep
200 you know soldiers there to guard the
oil
turns out there's way more way more
people on the ground and they
lied and the crazy thing is how the left
gloats and is laughing about
it the american people voted for a
president who said
i i am going to get our troops out of
these forever wars
and the american people want that to
happen yes so they lied to the president
they lied to us
and i my mind was is blown that after
after i saw that
i posted on facebook to all the people
who voted for joe biden
after everything the obama
administration did get getting us into
more foreign entanglements
more conflict in north africa in the
middle east i hope the blood of these
dead children weighs heavy on your
conscience every night you go to sleep
because you voted for this i voted for
obama the first time i learned my lesson
and then i walked away because that was
insane now we get donald trump and he
was not good in his first few years he
hired bolton i said all the time
what a dumb move but trump started
making good moves on foreign policy
now what happens they lie and then they
justify they laugh
and all of these people on the left i
posted this on facebook saying
when i said this really shocking thing
sure they were like well
trump should have known i'm like why are
you defending the war mongers who blow
up
kids yeah trump tried to get them out
they lied
well trump should he well trump is bad
so when i was on here last time we
talked about this we talked about how
the trump administration
had fired some people over at department
of defense and they had installed
some of their trump loyalists over there
and we joked around saying is this like
a head counting exercise what's going on
i think the
headline on that talk was is there a
coup coming we were joking around about
that so i
called my guys i have some sources in
the white house and i talked to them and
they told me and they assured me 100
that the entire reason that they have
made these personnel changes department
offense is to ensure
that the president's orders are
faithfully carried out and executed
to his desire within the law and with
the intent of the people that voted him
into office to remedy
what is happening in syria and to try to
end the wars and try to get our people
out and to do what was ordered from the
beginning
but he was thwarted by the deep state
you know it's not uh it's not a
conspiracy theory
the bureaucratic state the deep state
they have their own agendas they have
their own plans
and they are the ones that are in
control they the people in the field can
lie they can say the troops are there
they're not there
and so they put people now in to these
positions to make sure that the
president's
orders are faithfully executed i wish it
would have happened years ago
he's been he's been freaking you know
c-blocked the whole way he's been
totally stymied and everything but now
he's really trying to make that happen
and if you can do
that that's wonderful but it's also just
an example of how corrupt
the deep state is how corrupt the
moneyed military interests are how
corrupt our foreign policy is
and trump you know he gets a bad he gets
a bad rap but doesn't he
he has shown consistent sympathy for
children
and consistency well in some cases i
suppose
and consistently and consistently
wanting to
end war if i could just it was just
you know for me just kind of sitting
back but it was just disgusting to see
um all the mainstream media and
journalists just like laughing about it
almost like it was an inside joke
and it's just like it's it's it's our
middle class americans that we send to
those wars to go fight for you guys and
you guys just could sit back and laugh
and make all this money
it's absolutely sick and it's just sick
to see you know joe biden out here
toting you know black lives matter but
what about the black because that you
bombed
in the middle east all those years you
know you know you took us two to five
you know from two to seven wars and um
it's just to me it was it was
it was it was disgusting to see that
journalist liz just put uh you know
laughing emojis when like
dude it's our our american brothers and
sisters are over there man think about
the amount of money we spend to do all
that
while everyone's been complaining about
what's going on in flint michigan
i bring it up every time it's the
perfect example have we we haven't
solved the problem of the water crisis
in flint
yet you've got people laughing about how
they
lied to the american people to keep
troops in syria who wanted to go to
syria
obama did before the cutter turkey
pipeline and because we have we have
proxy wars over natural natural gas and
other resources look i totally get it
these people want to you know make make
good money and it's good for america and
everybody but is it worth destabilizing
the entire region
creating space for isis okay we
should not have been involved in this
you look at these photos man from from
from syria these photos from aleppo
there there are ancient structures there
are
thousands of years of ancient history
but you more than that the lives of
these families if you look at these
beautiful photos from aleppo before the
war
and then you look at after the war and
it's rubble chaos and death
that's what they wanted and for what
i'll tell you this
these people think we're gonna we're
gonna get our pipeline through sierra
through turkey we're gonna make cheap
gas available for the people in europe
and that sounds an awful lot like what
the left would call white supremacy
isn't it
they created a a refugee crisis where
people are fleeing on what's called the
eastern mediterranean route in boats
that are flipping over
capsizing kids are dying washing up on
shore and they say oh this problem
and i was there i i talked to some of
these refugees i talked to these people
and ever it seems like every single time
they try and manipulate me
to to give them support for these crises
they never want to actually solve them
they want to make them
worse so i tell you this is it good for
america if we get our natural gas in
europe offset the russian monopoly oh
it'll be great for us is it worth
all of the dead and displaced and the
chaos and the destruction absolutely
not but this is this is this is what we
get
when you have a bureaucratic class that
runs the government
it doesn't matter who you elect the the
democrats and the republicans the rhinos
and the dinos
are just once the keys to the castle you
vote for me i win the contest then i sit
back and pretend like i'm doing
something
when trump said i want to get our troops
out of the middle east what happens you
get all of these democrats republicans
saying no you can't do it even mitch
mcconnell's like no you can't do it our
allies in the region
shut up this is what the american people
want and they voted for trump for a
reason
that's a lot of establishment tim on
both sides are actually happy with joe
biden president's
presidency because then life in
washington goes back to the status quo
you know back to mo wars big business
everyone's making the number of the
middle class keeps
keeps getting keeps getting shrunk our
manufacturing jobs keep getting shipped
to china
and our suicide rate and our opioid
problems and middle america keep going
this country is being extracted dylan
ratigan said it i think it was seven
years ago in 2013 you see this famous
rant
where he said it's being extracted
through trade a bunch of other things
but this is what we get joe biden says
we're going to increase the corporate
tax rate
the obama administration wanted us in
the trans-pacific partnership a free
trade agreement
with pacific countries most namely china
that means that you put a factory in
china you can send all the goods back to
america free of charge
so you can use cheap sweat sweatshop
labor with no health insurance
no minimum wage and the people in china
are working like the foxconn factories
in such horrifying conditions
they walk off they put suicide nets up
around the building
that's what joe biden and the obama
administration were supporting
it's that china wasn't in the first tpp
oddly enough it was 13 yeah 13 pacific
countries but china wasn't one of them
although they've reformatted a new
pacific partnership
with now canada and china's in this one
so so here's what happens they're headed
for they're trying to get us into that
what do you think happens when you
increase the corporate tax rate to like
39.6 up from i think like 28 then you
say we're going to increase the minimum
wage to 15
but anything you make overseas can come
right back to this country
free of charge every company is going to
be like okay then we'll go to china
is that what you want us to do i'm not
going to do it and that means good
paying middle-class jobs gone the rich
get richer the poor get poorer
and now we got kovid now we got the
lockdowns coming back and fauci
fauci is saying a year quarter three
of 2021 until we go back to normal he
says and
one thing that just not it's i don't
know why it's not talked about
mainstream media it's
when these manufacturing jobs are
shipped now we have all these fathers
and dads in these communities with no
jobs
then they fall into depression now we
have divorce going up we have foster
care going up
opioid abuse going up this is not good
for for our country we need to we need
candidates like you know like more
populist working class
there was actually an interesting study
by heather lund from washington post she
put out this report that
a voters in the midwest who were more
afraid to lose their job to automation
and voted for trump voters who weren't
afraid of automation voted for biden i
think that says
everything about you that says
everything about who has the
working-class message
and who doesn't did you guys see the
video from the world economic forum
about not owning anything
yep in the video it says western values
have been uh tested to the breaking
point
and then it goes on to talk about how we
got to do something different
something different and we will create
they say our predictions
is that in the future you won't own
anything and you'll be happy
and maybe that's true if they take away
your ability to know
you know uh i was talking about this one
of my videos you guys
you guys have seen stargate right yes
and you've seen stargate with macgyver
yeah so when they go there he tries
drawing something on the ground and they
freak out
like no it's forbidden to write things
down people will be kept very happy
in their ignorance you take away their
ability to know how good things can
really be sure they'll be happy not
owning anything
what was the title of the article i
don't know anything or i don't own
anything i don't have any privacy
and life is better than i ever expected
absolutely amazing
why would they say that you're trying to
destroy the family so bad that's for
sure
uh that's all about uh blurring
boundaries yeah right
all this is about all this is about
indiscriminate connection no boundaries
communism what we need are is strategic
disconnection we need barriers that
allow what we want to come and go
this is a theme for the next 20 years
guys it's not about indiscriminate
connections it's about strategic
disconnection at this point
now what i want to know is the world
economic forum
the advocates of capitalism have they
been pushing neoliberal trade have they
been looking to reduce
the barriers between capital flows and
trade flows and labor flows
et cetera they're trying to universalize
the entire world with western economic
values and now they're saying
that they're flawed somehow i don't
understand that on the world economic
forum website
the values that built the west will have
been tested to breaking point
we forget the checks and balances that
bolster our democracies at our peril
writes kenneth roth executive director
of human rights watch
i am offended that they're using the
term checks and balances in this
instance
highly offended they extracted our
wealth with this federal reserve fiat
and now they're going to
crash us well i think they extracted our
wealth by
free trade agreements driving up minimum
wages which incentivizes companies take
advantage
of transferring the factories overseas
and then
to to add insult to injury they crank up
the corporate tax rate so the
companies are like we have no choice
we're going to give up 40 percent of our
revenue
unless we move to mexico or china let's
go
you know it's the first time in my life
i'm going to agree with the black bloc
protesters let's go back to the 1999
world trade organization the battle in
seattle
everybody was arguing free trade with
china means a race to the bottom on
wages a race to the bottom on human
rights issues
and a race to the bottom on the
environment and guess what
they weren't wrong in that regard they
were not wrong
those people are now the trump
supporters the the people that were
challenging that are still challenging
it
there are certainly a lot of people
probably at the battle in seattle who
were just there because they were part
of the leftists coalition definitely
now i was being a lawyer i mean but look
at look at occupy wall street
they were protesting the obama
administration now these people voted
for joe biden
that is injured thank you the
realignment
it's the sociological ignorance that
we've been foisted upon ourselves
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you